you're telling me this isn't what
Pokemon we're supposed to look like in
gen 1 the scans of these classic Pokemon
designs that we have all come to know
for decades well it turns out that they
actually sucked for years now scans of
the classic gen1 Ken sugamori artwork
has been available in these bad over
contrasted scans this has been the case
for so long now that I think most people
myself included thought that the way
that they looked was just part of the
intended styles for the illustrations of
the time but as it turns out nope
this is how they actually were supposed
to look the designs were finally
rescanned competently and the difference
is stack at a time I had Associated this
a Pokemon with these harsh contrasty
colors in both saturated Hues but seeing
them as they were intended it's wild to
see the nuance and color choices of
these original designs it's hard to let
go of my perception of the old scans
right now but you can't deny the
artistic intent here what do you guys
think